[Music]
foreign
what are the chances that I don't get
kicked off Twitter and YouTube just for
talking to you good solid 10 10 getting
kicked off or ten percent no no 10
staying on actually
[Music]
thank you
are you a good decent citizen are you
vaccinated it's nobody's business
whether I'm vaccinated that's like me
asking you the last time you got laid I
mean it's just irrelevant
[Music]
thank you
click subscribe and tap the Bell so you
get notified whenever we drop a new
video
[Music]
all right people this is it it is the
big August going off the grid show I am
Dave Rubin it is July 27th
2023 we are live streaming as always on
Rumble locals and uh well I said as
always but you never know when we'll be
kicked off YouTube uh but we are live
streaming there as far as I know right
now who knows by the time we get back uh
if you have not subscribed of course go
ahead and do that and I should know
there will be no post game show today
I'm going to tell you a whole bunch of
stuff get you caught up on a bunch of
stuff we've got a q a my best and
favorite moments uh from the past year
and then I am jumping over even though
this was planned to be it this next hour
this was it we were packing it all in
and then I'm disappearing until August
23rd this is a somewhat abbreviated off
the great August because as I've told
you guys the first Republican debate is
August 23rd in Milwaukee Wisconsin
Rumble is the exclusive live streamer so
it will be on Fox on television but
YouTube is not getting it nor is anybody
else if you want to stream it it's going
to be Rumble they are going to have a
huge setup there live audience I'm going
to be interviewing a bunch of the
candidates there so I'm coming back that
morning we just confirmed this morning I
don't want to say it yet because we'll
leave it as a surprise but my guest host
11 A.M on the 23rd big time Big Time
guest host will get me caught up on
everything I've missed in August and
then we will be doing pre and post
debate shows uh desantises committed
Nikki Haley's in I think Francis Suarez
is in pretty sure we got vivec we've
kind of buried the hatchet on that one
and we're going to work on everybody as
I said live studio audience it's going
to be awesome and I'm just going to shut
it down for the next couple weeks I'll
tell you a bit more we're building a new
studio this month so this is it say
goodbye to the old Reuben report Studio
we're moving we'll have more on that in
just a bit and for today as I said we're
going to recap a whole bunch of stuff
some of my favorite moments some of your
favorite moments we asked you guys and
uh and also a couple stories first
because oh uh not not a big deal but
they they found the aliens yeah they
found the aliens it's been confirmed and
the figures like that today's the day
they found the aliens yesterday I'm
leaving today like you know I could be
gone with the aliens for a month we'll
find out will the world be here who
knows uh before we do any of that though
let's talk about gravity to fire guys
how much is it worth not to feel pain
with every step you take from walking
the dog to running with the kids from
school to practice and everywhere else
it takes a toll well you guys need to
check out gravity to Fire Shoes whether
you're wearing them on the job or to get
your daily step count up these gravity
defyer shoes are revolutionary walking
and running in normal shoes creates
shock waves that course through your
feet knees and hips forcing the body to
absorb as much as a thousand pounds of
harmful impact with every step gravity
to fire shoes are clinically shown to
relieve knee pain in a double-blind
study by Olive View UCLA Medical Center
and published in the Journal of American
podiatric Medical Association
participants experienced 85 percent less
knee pain here's the deal guys it's
their it's the most powerful shock
absorption system put into a shoe so why
don't you do this how about try a pair
for 60 days and experience the
difference they can make in your life
buy a pair today and save 15 percent
with free returns and easy exchanges you
have nothing to lose visit
gravitytofire.com use code Reuben for 15
off discount on your first order test a
pair risk-free and experience the
difference in your life gravity2fire.com
use code Reuben for 15 discount on your
first order go to gravitytofire.com
order today I just realized
guys that I forgot that I started
telling you something then I jumped
right into the ad so we planned that
this was it like one hour Show Off the
Grid where is Dave Rubin going what's
happening nobody will know but then
yesterday uh Rudy texted me Rudy
Giuliani said I'm gonna be in Miami you
want to do something so I said Rudy for
you we will do a sit down so although
this is the official Off the Grid show
and after today the phone disappears no
more news none of that we will be doing
a live sit down we're gonna live stream
it live sit down with Rudy from the
local studio in Miami at one o'clock
today and that's it that's it although
we do have the locals meet up tonight so
it's it's the the grid is kind of it's
sucking me in the more I try to get out
the more it sucks me back in you guys
got it anyway let's get into some of the
craziness of the last day or so because
yes the aliens are here there was a
congressional hearing yesterday and a
UFO whistleblower under oath has
testified that non-biologics have landed
and well just take a look and it's like
I saw the story yesterday it's like at
this point does anything surprise us
does anything get the blood pressure to
go up does anything get the heart beat
faster does anything surprise any of us
I was like oh aliens what else is going
on on Twitter okay take a look
intelligent extraterrestrials
something I can't discuss in public
setting
um okay and I can't ask when you think
this occurred if you believe we have
crashed craft stated earlier do we have
the bodies of the pilots who piloted
this craft
as I've stated publicly already in my
news Nation interview biologics came
with some of these recoveries yeah
um
were they I guess human or non-human
biologics
non-human and that was the assessment of
people with direct knowledge on the
program I talked to that are currently
still on the program and was this
documentary references video photos
eyewitness like how would that be
determined
the specific documentation I would have
to talk to you in a skiff about gotcha
um okay
you may or may not be able to answer my
last question and maybe we get into a
skiff at the next hearing that we have
but who in the government either what
agency sub-agency what contractors who
should be called into the next hearing
about uaps either in a public setting or
even in a private setting and you
probably can't name names but what
agencies or organizations contractors
Etc do we need to call in to get these
questions answered whether it's about
funding what programs are happening and
what's out there I can give you a
specific cooperative and hostile witness
list of specific individuals that were
in those and how soon can we get that
list
I'm happy to provide that to you after
the hearing super thank you and I yield
back all right so we will find out I
suppose what they talked about after the
hearing but to be clear
non-biologics not or biologics but
non-human biologics so not humans were
something biological was found in some
sort of what we what appears to be a
crash craft or something like we're
entering Men In Black phase of this
whole thing which kind of seems like
where this was all added I suppose we
will find out more or we will not or
this is all kfabe and we're just playing
along in a script or who the hell knows
or will be slaves to the aliens or God
knows what else is going on but I saw
the story yesterday and I was like okay
it's the right time to go off the grid
like if the aliens are here and over the
next couple weeks we find out in the
invasion and War of the Worlds and
they're using us as Chum and the rest of
it
was nice knowing you guys I really
enjoyed all of this and uh we shall see
but also really it was also like man I'm
looking at this story and that you have
someone testifying under oath that that
agencies know about non-biologics found
in these crafts sorry not non-biologics
non-human biologics found in these
crafts and it's like nobody really cared
like everyone just keeps fighting about
Trump to say at this everyone's fighting
about who's racist they're not racist
who's you know dicks we're going to chop
off and all the rest of the nonsense and
that just is exactly why I go off the
grid because the endless hamster wheel
of everything you gotta stop it every
now and again so I just want to do one
other story before we get to everything
else related to the to the off the great
August situation because this week we
covered quite extensively uh that many
people on mainstream media the Democrats
all the usual hysterics were very upset
because in this new curriculum through
the far the Florida
Board of Education they were very upset
about how they were going to teach about
slavery and of course we looked into it
and it's basically uh I think you can
say this in an objective manner like the
most robust
um assessment of slavery and a true
history of slavery that probably exists
in any state what was getting a whole
bunch of people was there it was in
essence and by the way contrary to what
Kamala Harris said and contrary to what
Whoopi Goldberg said there were several
black Scholars who were part of creating
this curriculum but what was getting a
lot of people was that there was a line
or two in the curriculum related to how
black slaves attained certain skills
that then they were able to use in life
in the future while they were slaves and
somehow that was whitewashing slavery
now the simple thing as I addressed the
other day is it's it's obviously true
people that were blacksmiths on on
plantations you attain skills and then
once they were freed slaves they were
able to either become blacksmiths or use
some of those skills that's not a excuse
about slavery by any estimation the same
thing could be said for concentration
camps when people had to do jobs there
they might have been able to take some
of those skills and use them after again
not an excuse at all but everyone
started going completely bananas about
this in Florida's racist DeSantis is
Hitler too blah blah blah blah blah well
you are not going to believe what
happens check this tweet out this is
from Jerry Jeremy Redfern he says
remember when Florida wouldn't allow
that AP African-American studies course
because it focused too much on critical
race Theory and not enough on history
and the White House lost its mind well
here's one of the standards considered
Essential Knowledge so you guys remember
this of course a few months ago when
DeSantis banned this AP class because
they were going to have gender theory in
it and everyone was saying this AP class
must be taught it must be taught and
everyone said Florida was racist again
well look what's in that AP course that
they said must be taught in addition to
agricultural work enslaved people
learned specialized trades and worked as
painters Carpenters tailors musicians
and healers in the North and South once
free American Americans use these skills
to provide for themselves and others
should we just go off the grid right now
like that is such a perfect example of
how everything is BS how it's all virtue
signaling it's all fake and crazy and
designed and as I said before kfabe
k-a-y-f-a-b-e Google it if you don't
know what it is it's basically that
we're in this fake reality kfabe was the
the word that described that you'd be
watching an old WWE match back in the
day Hulk Hogan versus Andre the Giant
and you knew it was staged you knew it
was fake but it could bring out these
emotions with with you real emotions and
then they'd continue this story this
fake story about the Giant and the
American hero and we'd all be we're
living in it now but that story is the
most perfect example of all of it months
ago we were all racist because he wanted
to get that course out now that course
has exactly the same thing that is in
the course right now
it's just nuts but let me just do one
other thing on Florida then we will get
to everything else and again between
aliens and just like the lying about the
place that I live in that has that has
allowed my life to flourish and all that
stuff it's exactly why I go off the grid
so I can get fresh eyes on all of these
crazy things CNN put up a video
yesterday about a family that is fleeing
Florida because of how how evil
and of course transphobic Florida is
it's it's a two-parter here's part one
we just thought it would be a nice warm
place to live where we could get to
beaches
I just never thought that I would have
to flee a state for the good of my
children
the SB 254 uh this will permanent Outlaw
the mutilation of miners
I remember Tori coming to me one time
and in tears what she doesn't normally
do and I asked her what was wrong and
she said to Santas and like the fact
that a governor would be making my kid
cry that's a messed up government
we're absolutely moving because of the
political climate and the laws in
Florida we didn't want to move
when the Florida Board of Medicine
started meeting and we realized that
they were going to ban gender affirming
care for kids that we might need to
leave because that is life-saving
essential medicine and treatment for our
daughter
I was very relieved when we decided to
leave I had never really heard that much
about trans people and until I was like
11 or 12 I didn't even know trans people
existed so I was just used to being
uncomfortable I started hormone blockers
pretty soon after that
three
yeah I mean there was times before she
started getting hormones and stuff that
she was suicidal but after she
transitioned she was much more outgoing
much more like comfortable with herself
okay that's only part one first off
before I say anything or make any
sarcastic or glib remarks and talk about
the general insanity and that CNN is
pushing this and everything else this
has nothing to do with this kid right
like I'm not making fun of this kid and
I actually have great sympathy for this
kid not exactly for the reasons that CNN
wants you to think you should have
sympathy for this kid but for what the
parents have done for this kid for what
the world and the culture has done to
this kid and all of those things there's
so much Insanity there first off that
the woman says you know she walks in one
day Tori walks in one day what's wrong
DeSantis like it's just made uh what's
what's wrong what's wrong DeSantis
Ronald descent is like okay it's just
made up drivel this thing about gender
affirming care as you guys know it's not
affirming to chop off a child's genitals
that would be item unaffirming let's say
and
that at 11 years old I had never heard
much the kid says I had never heard much
about trans stuff then 11 years old then
they say soon after on hormone blockers
oh so do you think there might be a
social contagion element to it suddenly
you're at school and everyone's telling
you how great trans stuff is you're 11
years old you're confused about your
body your life all of the things yada
yada yada next thing you know they're
putting you on drugs and literally
chopping your genitals off and they're
framing this as positive and that the
state that's trying to stop these kids
from having their lives and bodies
destroyed is negative anyway here's part
two
okay careful
we are seeing many families that are
leaving I really think if you were to
ask a member of a trans family they
would tell you they go to bed at night
dreaming of how to get out of the state
so that yeah that's the dining room
right here and then this is the living
room My Hope for the McKee family is
they are able to find a community that
Embraces them
we're lucky that we're able to get out
we're able to afford to leave a lot of
people can't or it's going to be very
difficult I
feel really bad for the people that have
to stay here it's been difficult to
access my hormones I'm not honestly sure
how I would continue to access care even
if I wasn't trans I wouldn't be
comfortable here it's just not a safe
environment for queer people in general
I do fear for my daughter's safety and
just the fact that somebody might want
to hurt her just for her being her for
her existence is scary I worry about her
every time she goes out
almost the wide open view yeah sunsets
are great from here no
I'm looking forward to just being in a
place where I don't feel under attack
where I don't feel oppressed it's just
so sad that our country and our society
are in this place of denigrating people
like that and making them feel like they
have no place it's just hard to start
over all over again
[Music]
foreign
guys this is exactly like that level of
propaganda that you just saw there and
that they're attacked and all of this
stuff in Florida is not safe for queer
people and and that somehow chopping
genitals is good and and dealing with
deep psychological issues somehow is not
all of the nonsense it's exactly why I
go off the grid like to be able to do
what I do and keep it as I said with
fresh eyes and with an open mind and no
reality because otherwise we are just
slammed right we are just slammed with
this Insanity all the time I I would
like to note that CNN that put that
video out yesterday they got ratioed to
high hell I've mentioned to you guys
that aren't on Twitter ratio is when you
put up a video and you know let's say it
gets 10 retweets and 20 likes but then
it has like 3 000 comments because
everyone is like that is pure deranged
BS and that's what happened to CNN
anyway so all of that being said between
aliens between the machine trying to
trans our children and the rest of the
craziness guys this is exactly why I go
off the grid so now let's shift into
that portion of the show I want to say
that uh you know since last August I
mean there has never been an Off the
Grid August I believe this is my seventh
off the great August uh there has never
been uh an August to August situation
that my life changed more than it
changed uh this past year we were
blessed with Justin last August and then
and then Luke in October
and as I've said on the show you know I
try to do some
decent somewhat respectful balance of my
my personal and private life and then
the the public version of me and you
know those of you that are part of the
locals Community you get to see a little
bit more of the personal stuff
um but you know becoming a father this
year has like just absolutely changed
everything and to have it not just in
essence be about me all the time or what
I'm doing or what's going on on the
weekend or what are we eating tonight or
whatever that there are these little
humans in this house that uh that you
gotta love and take care of and and that
are more important than you and all of
those things and and that also even this
year is why I want to do the Off the
Grid to you know every day I get to
spend a certain amount of time with them
when I'm working or on the weekends more
time but really like hunker down with
them and you know Justin's basically
walking now he's right right on the cusp
and they're starting a couple words
they're starting to bubble out from each
of them and like it's really just been
uh it's been incredible in that you guys
by supporting us we are completely
independent didn't and will always stay
completely independent but you guys by
supporting us allow me to take this
little bit of time to just like clean my
brain and you know when I mentioned
before this thing about the hamster
wheel like every day for the rest of my
life as long as I do this show
um we could wake up and there are more
stories
doesn't matter if Trump ends up
president or DeSantis or it's Biden or
Newsom or World War III starts or the
aliens invade or whatever there are
always more stories there are always
more things to cover there's another
Barbie movie to be angry about and this
thing happened and that guy said this
and oh we found out that guy did that 20
years ago like there's it will always
exist and when I've gone off the grid
major things have happened last year was
it last year or the year before I don't
even remember anymore I missed the
Mar-A-Lago read that was last year right
that was last year it happened like
August 2nd so for a month I did not even
know about the Mar-A-Lago raid I came
back on the grid and I was like well I
don't think anything's going to really
come of it and you know in essence
nothing has although there's a whole
bunch of indictments I guess
quasi-related to that I miss John McCain
dying one year I missed the Afghanistan
withdrawal the year before that I missed
Andrew Cuomo uh stepping down like
things happen but the world continues
but I think for me to do this and make
sure that I don't have blind spots all
the time like right now I'm very much in
the thick of like what's happening in
presidential politics right I'm
obviously supporting the scientists I'm
trying to
push back on some of the lives wherever
they come from but I might have blind
spots right and I think stepping away
from some of this to to get like a clear
look on this thing as opposed to just
every day oh this happened holy
react and fight and capital letters
destroy and all of that stuff uh that's
really why I do this I think it's good
for me mentally and spiritually you know
it was five years ago or so that I came
back on the grid and I said I was no
longer an atheist which pissed off a lot
of people
um but you know when you give your your
mind
and your body and your spirit a little
time uh you never know what could happen
so for those of you uh that are watching
this I know most people can't do a full
August Off the Grid without this thing
and without a computer and I do like the
extreme extreme level of it but I hope
you guys will just try a couple days
here maybe just the weekends maybe take
a week maybe take the last week of
August whatever it might be to to give
yourself that space too because the
endless Doom scrolling on this thing you
know we are trapped in The Matrix but
it's your choice you know the Matrix is
always it's always growing and it's
expanding and it finds ways to wedge
itself in our lives non-stop in every
turn right and like it's just nuts but
you can figure out how much you want to
be a part of it even as it endlessly
encroaches on you so I hope that you'll
try to do a little of that as well uh
and now I just want to go through uh
some of my favorite moments of the last
year since starting in last September
and then a couple questions from the uh
from the locals Community uh so let's
start back in September right when I
came back on the grid I think you've
seen this one once or twice but I
finally got to sit down with Bill Maher
who of course I had wanted to sit down
with forever have my frustrations wanted
to find the common ground and I I think
we managed to do it you must know that
the Universe really doesn't give a
about you it is not sending you messages
I think you can find messages within the
nonsense from the universe we've called
the universe or whatever there are it's
not all random here we are in club not
all it's not all completely random
if you would have said to me in 1997
Dave you're going to be sitting with
Bill Maher at his house he's going to be
smoking pot Chevy Chase was just there
before blah blah blah you'd be married
to a dude Bill Maher would be talking to
you about anal sex like that is so
bananas my head would have exploded
so that's how uh the year I think of my
year sort of starting in September like
our season goes September to the end of
July that's how the year started off and
I think in many ways
um all of the things that I've been
doing like I think I'm moving Bill a
little bit on the universe this is not
all random I think most people whether
you want to go deeply spiritual and God
and biblical stuff or just like a little
more sense to the universe it's not I
just it's so obvious it's not all
coincidence it's not all random there is
some order to this we all we all can
find those moments in in those peaceful
times that we have it's partly what why
again why I do the Off the Grid August
thing just a couple days after that
October rolled around and then I had one
of the sort of biggest moments of my
professional life that was that one was
professional and personal the bill thing
obviously but this was uh professionally
probably the biggest moment of my life I
was there as Rumble we rang the bell in
New York at the NASDAQ Stock Exchange
that's of course Dan bongino on the
other side died and Chris pavlovski
who's the CEO of Rumble and a South Leb
who's also my brother-in-law co-founder
of locals locals in Rumble had merged
right before this and here we are this
is as the bell rang I think we've got
some video on that do we yeah so we had
just rang the bell and the company went
public and Free Speech really is public
there we go
um free speech is public now Rumble is
publicly traded uh I know a whole bunch
of you are are in on it and I assure you
and and that's why I'm doing this show
through Rumble and through locals and
everything else like we are fighting for
the right reasons I will give you just
one great example of how uh Rumble is
fighting for free speech in a way that
no other big tech company including
Twitter is
um during when the whole Russia Ukraine
war blew up
um Russia no sorry France basically
contacted Rumble and said if you don't
take down some of your Russian channels
that are on Rumble including RT which is
Russian television we're going to ban
you from France and we said we're not
taking them down you can ban us and we
are banned in France right now for
standing up for the right thing not even
Twitter is doing that so I'm I'm just
super proud to be part of that and the
fact that the company went public is is
just awesome and there's obviously a lot
of a lot of good Returns on that and and
it's just great uh November uh this was
my favorite moment of November I'm sure
it was a favorite moment for many of you
this was on election night and of course
we did not get that Red Wave we wanted
but there was a massive landslide in
Florida that clearly led to a whole
bunch of other stuff you may remember
this
[Applause]
oh it's cold that was it that was it
that was it 15 points 50 I told the
governor I told the governor on June 2nd
the Two of Us in Orlando in the green
room I said you're gonna win by 15
points he laughed in my face all right
Governor DeSantis
all right so that was obviously at the
DeSantis Victory party it turned out by
later in the evening he won by 20 and a
half points or so I think 1.6 million
votes I was sitting there of course with
Liz wheeler and that was a great night
as a Floridian it maybe wasn't a great
night for the country although the
Republicans did get the house back and
that has somewhat slowed a little bit of
the craziness but kind of not really who
knows uh but that was that was certainly
a highlight and just just being there in
the in the atmosphere there and the like
Spirit of freedom and all that good
stuff uh December was a great one I got
to interview Bibi Netanyahu with just
the the simple fact that I'm able to
talk to these people who are hugely
influential uh in the world that are
people that are literally changing
things on the ground that that matter in
in a way bigger way than I ever would
have thought I would have been affecting
things you know 20 years ago it's kind
of nut so here's just a portion of that
I think it's a miracle of faith and
resolution Israel because of the
resolution the resolve of its citizens
The Genius of its people has become the
Juggernaut uh Innovation nation in the
world and we have uh we've just crossed
in GDP we've crossed Japan
France Britain
um and Germany GDP per capita and
remember when I I described this in my
book when we began the economic
Revolution uh towards free markets away
from socialism we were basically the
last place in Western Europe and now
we're pretty much in first place and
we're we're going to catch up with the
United States that's
a personal Quest I'm not saying but
we'll catch up with you guys and
hopefully going forward after this we'll
keep talking to Prime Ministers and
presidents of all political stripes and
from all over the world and uh just
making the conversation a little more
enriched and and to continue it uh
January was pretty awesome because you
know the the whole Elon Twitter thing
really in some ways was the biggest sort
of media Story of the Year Elon buying
Twitter the exposing so much of the
nonsense around Twitter so I got I was
invited like out of nowhere I got a call
at about 1pm uh eastern time can you get
to to San Francisco to meet Elon tonight
and uh I somehow got on a plane I was
literally on the last row in the in the
middle seat and I got to to uh Twitter
headquarters and then I put out a long
Twitter Thread about what I saw Twitter
and and really the beautiful part is
what you're seeing the last line in that
Twitter thread I sat with Elon for a
couple hours and a bunch of Engineers
and they showed me all of the all of the
stuff and all of the Shadow Banning they
were uncovering and all of the craziness
that was going on over there and I said
to Elon because there were I had no
expectations when I went there I didn't
know was I doing the Twitter files am I
just meeting the guy like her like what
the hell am I even doing there and I
said to him after a couple hours hey can
I can I just tweet about what I saw here
and his response was just beautiful he
says you can say anything that is true
uh anything that's true and it's like
that really is the spirit that we need a
bit more of these days and I think one
of the reasons that right now there's a
chance right like imagine if he did not
get Twitter even if you're not on
Twitter like imagine how much stronger
the censorship machine would be right
now yeah we'd have Rumble yeah we'd have
locals but like Twitter is the
ubiquitous app and it's becoming more
ubiquitous at the moment because you
know he's turning Twitter he wants to
turn it into the everything app which he
just basically renamed the company X and
they want to do a whole sort of revamp
of that but I think we have a chance
with that so that was that was sort of a
beautiful moment my favorite moment out
of February was it was the what what was
it the seven year anniversary if I'm not
mistake it was the six year anniversary
of my first uh video that I ever did for
prageru the the now famous or inFAMOUS
why I left the left video I subsequently
did three more videos so we thought for
the anniversary of that why don't we
kind of recap my political Adventure
because it's mirrored so many other
political uh people's political
Adventures including guys like Elon Musk
for example here's a little trailer we
put together on that one so this month
is the sixth year anniversary of the
famous or inFAMOUS why I left the left
video that I did for prageru you may
remember it might be hard for you to
remember but you might remember that I
once was a good Lefty I was a liberal I
was a Democrat all of those nice things
and then things started to change my
side the left was actually the ones that
were acting completely illiberately we
were the ones who were silencing free
speech on campus and shouting down
speakers we were focused on the
collective instead of the individual it
was also talking to people that I
thought were my ideological enemies
whether they were Dennis Prager or Glenn
Beck or Larry Elder or Jordan Peterson
or Ben Shapiro or the list goes on I was
willing to talk to people hear what they
had to say and then compare that to my
own thoughts I think everything that
I've spent the last couple years talking
about is exactly what is needed in
America right now it's imperfect I'm
imperfect you're imperfect but if we
fight for those ideals and if we act a
little bit more bravely and we turn back
to some of those founding documents that
sometimes seem old and irrelevant I
really think we can fix this thing I'm
Dave Rubin of the Rubin report stealing
these short videos from prageru to shoot
this film
whatever
you can check out that compilation why
don't we link to that can we link to
that in the description we're going to
put that in the description right now so
you can check that out a little bit
later if you haven't seen it we take all
four of our videos and really tell a
story over the last couple years that I
think we'll we'll uh well a lot of you I
think will relate to it uh in March the
Highlight for sure was our trip to DC
where I interviewed about 18 Republicans
not one Democrat we reached out to about
20 Democrats the only Democrat who even
responded to us was Rashida Talib of all
people who said no but we got pretty
much every Republican we wanted the
highlight of course was we went to the
Capitol and a whole bunch of you guys
from locals joined us I think about 60
70 people joined us and we went and we
interviewed Kevin McCarthy right in
front of you guys it was really great
take a look not a perfect Nation we
strive to be a more perfect Nation but
we should be more patriotic
I mean this idea and this is goes long
answer to your short question I will put
bills on the phone I don't even remember
the question
I think I asked you what it's like to
work in a place where people don't like
you okay so we had a resolution on the
floor denouncing socialism okay this is
not a college campus this is not
Berkeley this is people elected to the
U.S House of Representatives with all
the history of America and a hundred
Democrats couldn't vote no
can you believe that
so it goes back to your question could I
believe that not one Democrat would
stand up that's an extreme position that
was a really beautiful day we then took
tours everybody that joined us got to
take a tour of the capital and Kevin
McCarthy's speaker McCarthy's team was
were great they led to all the tours I
jumped around with everybody it was just
really wonderful uh April the Highlight
was definitely this moment I did uh
Patrick Bet David's podcast which
they've now got a live studio up in Fort
Lauderdale and they had me and Rudy
Giuliani I'm going to see Rudy a little
later today they had us on the panel
together this was I think the Highlight
moment
could you guys Google it does she have a
dick and
the fact that I just said that in front
of Rudy Giuliani
911 like this guy is a true hero and I
apologize for even doing that I don't
know what a meme is but I know what a
dick is
[Music]
[Applause]
don't worry thank you good night
I have to say like honestly I'm almost
tearing up as I'm watching that because
you know I I lived in New York City as I
said during 9 11 most of my formative
years and doing stand-up and struggling
and being freaking broke literally going
to my roommate's coffee jar to in
essence steal change but I guess I was
borrowing it's still Mike I owe you a
couple bucks uh like to take change so I
get a cup of coffee literally when I had
no money and I was sleeping on a cot in
a hallway just doing stand-up at night
while that guy was mayor of New York
City and that then I'm up there with him
as an equal like doing these things and
I'm going to do something with him later
um and yeah it's just uh what a what a
weird wild adventure uh May was awesome
May was absolutely great May of course
we did our big Israel hungry trip I
think we've got a couple pictures of
some of the highlights So that obviously
is in Jerusalem the Western Wall right
behind me Dome of the Rock right behind
that that's former Ambassador David
Friedman who of course was really the
the lead of the Abraham Accords uh let's
see I think we have a video from then we
went up to the north to Lebanon this is
wild so we were right if you did not see
this we are right on the border between
Lebanon and Israel here and we're at a
we're at a bunker here where there's
guns aiming each way and they just let
me the Israelis kind of live on the edge
they let me wander in the border between
Israel and Lebanon obviously we're on
the Israeli side but right through there
we're standing and I suppose some sort
of a bunker here with a little vantage
point but right through there that Black
Tower you're seeing there is fairly new
over the last couple months that's a
Hezbollah Tower where they can monitor
and see what's going on here in Israel
they just shot about I think it was 36
rockets in the last uh two weeks or so
but mostly what I'm noticing here is
that the Israelis are building a wall
it's almost complete at least in this
section and I guess walls sometimes do
work
you know seeing that stuff like so
granularly so like right in front of
your face when you see a border and
they're like oh
whether they're good guys or bad guys or
whatever like our territory ends here if
you put up a wall it does kind of stop
people from jumping over and it does
delineate between one territory and
another so they're building their wall
there and will we ever get a wall built
will we ever take care of our border we
shall see uh after Israel we went right
over to Hungary which was fantastic we
went to Budapest and the the Highlight
well there were many highlights I did I
did a really what was one of the most
enjoyable talks of my entire life at the
Danube Institute which you're seeing
over there which that video is up on uh
YouTube and Rumble right now you can
check that out if you want it was a real
pleasure to do that and then totally
impromptu we happened to be next door to
the prime minister's residence and they
were able to set up a meeting between me
and Victor Orban and Victor Orban who's
you know in Western media is thought of
as a very dangerous scary fascist and I
meet the guy and he's like laughing and
smiling he's like I just like my culture
and I like my people I want to protect
it that's it you know so that was that
was nice and then uh Ben also sort of by
coincidence so that is she's the uh
Caitlyn Novak is the president right she
is the president of Hungary Caitlin
Novak and this is backstage Jordan
Peterson happened to be doing a show in
Budapest this the day before we were
leaving we were taking like a 5 a.m
flight so I got to do the show with
Jordan open for him about 6 000 people
and anything with JP is always great and
uh that was that was really fantastic uh
in June now we're almost caught up
people I promise in June I think the
Highlight was I headed out to Nevada and
I did an event for a couple thousand
people with Governor DeSantis this
obviously is just right after he
announced that he was running for
president and uh there's no audio to
that video and people have tried to
figure out what we were saying to each
other there uh but uh he's out there now
you guys know how I feel about wanting
to export Florida to America right make
America Florida by the way we have make
America Florida shirts which we just
redesigned I had put a little green in
there that people felt was making a
little too much like the Italian flag we
have now redesigned them in red white
and blue you can find them at Dave
rubin.store the make America Florida
shirt and then the highlight of July was
you know I've been talking so much about
how there is this incredible
cross-section of people all over the
political map all over the cultural map
who are trying to come together to make
some sense of the world that's really
what I was focused on this particular
this last few days and really what I'm
going to be thinking about and churning
through and trying to
trying to shape as I said yesterday
right uh when I'm off the grid uh and
the conversation that I had most related
to that in July was with RFK Jr
I actually retweeted it and I asked
people to come up with some of your
dangerous ideas and nobody seems to
really know what they are but that
doesn't stop the New York Times
yeah and all of my conspiracy theories
as it turns out have come true
oh yeah they're no longer there is there
you know they're now a proven hypotheses
but
you know what I I do wonder about it I
you know I was thinking about this this
morning
that I'm because the the this kind of
this hail storm of negative publicity
about I mean really kind of not
it goes beyond like hit pieces it's to
be as is you know poisonous of Israel
um and that it's coming from all the
Legacy Media from the Atlantic Monthly
from New York Magazine New York or the
Washington Post and the New York Times
from Vanity Fair
The Daily Beast uh Daily Coast
Rolling Stone
and and many many others
and they all kind of use the same
talking points and uh and they also are
not accurate you know none of them has
really written an accurate
and that's one of the reasons it doesn't
trouble me is because it's it's just uh
it's just inaccuracies all right so
there there is a chance guys again you
don't have to agree with everything RFK
says you don't have to agree with
everything I say I don't agree with
everything RFK says he don't agree with
everything I say but this wide swath of
people from Mar and Peterson and Rogan
and vivec and RFK this wide swath of
people try and adjust make some sense of
this thing it's better than the hacks
and the sellouts and the Liars right and
there's an awful lot of them and they're
super powered by algorithms and
corporate press and the rest of it but
like if we can piece together that thing
it's it literally is the only way out it
really is and now ladles and jelly
spoons let's get to a Reuben report
Community Q a I know there's a bunch of
stuff about uh Off the Grid and some
other political rating things and and
personal things and a bunch more here we
go Bonnie says you've inspired me the
last few years to put down the devices I
don't go full dark but it's nice to get
away from the insanity for a while enjoy
your time off with the family see you on
the flip side well that's not even a
question but I appreciate that and I'm
thrilled to hear that like really anyone
watching this when's the last time you
took one day could you do it could you
take one day without this thing can you
walk out of your house I got one for you
guys in this room when's the last time
you walked out of your house without
this thing for five hours Daphne you're
my assistant so you're not allowed but
anyone else like never for Daphne Connor
really when's the last time you walked
around for five hours without this thing
when he was 12 last time last
week
Phoenix takes Dave rubin's advice last
weekend you did it like for an afternoon
good for you man Brock definitely not
you're my social media guy the guy's got
Tick Tock lot he has a phone actually
like lodged in the side of his brain
Michaela what about you you're the
youngest here Michaela The Intern
[Music]
Michaela the intern does not have her
phone on her often interesting Michaela
the intern we will have to find out more
about it but really guys I mean it like
if you can just try a little little
break you just don't know what it'll do
to you I'm telling you I start
remembering songs out of nowhere I can
remember every lyric like two weeks in
it starts like the first couple days are
kind of weird and I'm grabbing from my
phone and like there's this weird
tension and then it starts and then it's
like really great and then I'm
remembering songs I literally am
remembering like it'll be like I'll be
like out of nowhere I'm like oh that
What about Brian from third grade who
sat behind me like whatever happened to
him like these these odd things there's
so much that is buried in our brains and
if you can CL clear the Clutter you can
get to some good stuff you really can
because it's in there I promise you it's
always says since this is your last
broadcast until the 23rd of August what
would be your advice for those in the
locals Community to keep our sanity
until your return well look as I said I
want you guys to take some time off but
as I address yes yesterday because of
the way the algorithms work we are going
to still put up a bunch of content
Phoenix can you list out some of the
interviews that we've done we have a
whole bunch of stuff stacked uh that
we're going to put up in August we also
I taped like 30 intros to things like if
the view ladies go crazy if Joy Reed
says something nuts if Biden croaks like
we did we did like it would be funny to
release all those intros regardless of
what happens uh but we've got we've got
a whole bunch of people I interviewed
Glenn Beck we're going to put that up uh
Bjorn lomberg Carol Roth Larry Elder Gad
said Marissa stride from prageru Chris
Ruffo who's uh who's Greg which Greg is
that oh Greg Gutfeld Jesus
you see why I need a break people so we
did like just in these last couple days
we did like 10 interviews so you're
gonna get a whole bunch of stuff and I
hope more than anything you guys will
keep communicating and keeping each
other alive and and attached in a
certain way but not like obsessively ah
chewing on this thing Dan says who you
who have you lined up to interview you
when you returned from Off the Grid we
just found out this still this morning
it's a major major major person but I
just don't want to say anything right
now but we will be live from Milwaukee
rumbles building a huge set at the venue
where the debates will be live studio
audience how many people they said a
couple hundred people right like
it's going to be awesome and it's a big
name I promise you you will you will you
will be pleased uh Amy Says since movies
have been a Hot Topic this week I'm
wondering if there are any movies You
Remember Loving as a kid that you
re-watched in adulthood and realized
they weren't that great or the opposite
movies you hated as a kid but now like
as an adult oh
that's a good question something
something I loved as a kid
that I hate now
nothing's really do you guys have
anything nothing's really coming to mind
Connor you you usually have my
references what do you got like
something
yeah you know it's uh that's yeah yeah
that's like kind of ballparking what my
answer was going to be it's funny like
now especially because of the kids like
I don't have we just don't have time to
watch movies anymore like it's very rare
and at the end of the day like I'm beat
David's beat it's like it's a lot so
what we do is sometimes on the weekends
we just kind of put on movies and we're
just like kind of checking in and out
but I'd make sure not to leave the kids
just sitting in front of the TV but like
if the kids take a nap we'll just put on
something and I just put on any crazy
80s movie and I and I just love them
like whether it's a Schwarzenegger or a
Stallone movie or whether it's Mr Mom or
mannequin or Weekend at Bernie's or
Weekend at Bernie's too which is one of
the worst movies of all time but you can
just watch them and they're like
Pleasant and you can check in and out
and yeah that didn't really answer your
question but that that's kind of it for
me Kathy says how are you planning to
celebrate Justin's first birthday where
you're off the grid that's right so
Justin was his due date was August 22nd
he was born on August 6th uh we there's
a serious balloon situation happening
and a few other surprises we have not
given the kids any kind of sugar yet
these kids are eating so well like
healthy organic everything I make them
eggs every morning I'm thinking we gotta
like I gotta I don't know if I can tell
David this everyone keep this quiet but
maybe I can smuggle him like a little
piece of a donut or something I'm gonna
do I'm gonna do a little something thank
God David doesn't watch the show uh
Michael says uh Dave you stay busy with
family and work you even find time for
fans and supporters would you take a
position within the DeSantis
Administration cabinet Communications
um I really don't think so I I don't
think so like
my life is good I love what we're doing
here
um we're working on some other things
related to the show as I said we're
building a new studio but we're working
on some other live things that I think
we can probably pull off in the fall and
a bunch more but I think I'm affecting
things at the right level if you just
watch the 12 months that I recap like
I'm I'm doing things that I think are
matter and relevant and
um I don't want to move to DC I mean do
you know that I love Florida have you
heard me say that like the idea of
moving to DC but I will put one little
caveat in there if DeSantis became the
president and I got the call to do
something like would I say no to the to
the country for the betterment of the
country if they thought I could be part
of that
um I would try to work out something
where I don't know maybe I could do
Fridays like you know they get the press
secretary whoever that might be maybe
Christina Bouchard or whoever and like
every now and again you know there's
always a backup like we see this uh you
know we've got cringe Jean-Pierre but
every now and again it's somebody else
like maybe I could be that person I
could wear those outfits that cringe
wears those very colorful tight-knit
things and I could get up there and make
my hair all crunchy and then just say
nothing I could do that uh Tony says uh
thinking back on your previous off the
grids what's the most interesting or
surprising thing that happened in the
world while you were away uh well the
Afghanistan in terms of politics
uh can you find what what was the date
of the Afghanistan withdrawal I think it
was very early on in August if I'm not
mistaken it was like the first week in
August maybe second week in August so I
had no idea about that for a couple
weeks and for me to see those videos
those insane you know you you all saw
them you saw them when it was happening
those crazy videos of people jumping on
the planes and falling off and just
watching us leave all of that stuff that
we left and like the human toll and the
the utter embarrassment for our our
military and for the Biden
Administration to whitewash it like that
like it's it's it's pretty rare that
anything politically can kind of shock
you and we did have to wrap up
Afghanistan where everyone no one knew
why we were there anymore it had nothing
to do with 911 and attack them there so
they don't attack us here okay but you
know what was it 19 of the planners were
from Saudi Arabia or whatever like
yeah that was one that shocked me it was
the withdrawal was on August 15th so
right in the middle of the month right
in the middle of month Dave says great
name Dave tell me you're planning at
least one smoke all day while you chill
out brisket oh duh yeah I mean there's
gonna be I actually just went to our our
wild Fork place I always wild Fork is
that just the Florida operation are they
all over the place
right now yeah so wild Fork is a brick
and mortar place where you can get they
have incredible frozen meats they're not
a sponsor I do obviously I do a ton with
moink and I'm always doing all my stuff
but I just went to for bigger Cuts I've
been going to this place wild Fork where
you can get these massive freaking
tomahawks I did like a 16 pound brisket
for my family so yeah we're gonna be I'm
going to smell like smoke throughout
most of August for sure and maybe we'll
let Brock post some pictures of of meats
if we can make that happen uh Ben says
predictions for when you come back will
the aliens have landed will Joe Biden be
revealed as king of the zombies will
Gavin Newsom have declared his 2024
presidential campaign I mean look any
year anything can happen this year feels
and especially because I'm so in the
thick of it like this year feels
particularly insane which is exactly why
I have to go off the grid which is also
you know the debate I really didn't want
the debate to be in August I just feel
like especially because of my situation
with Rumble it's and and everything that
I'm fighting for
in with DeSantis here like I just felt
like I had to come back a bit early by
the way so we're going to come back a
bit early on the on the 23rd and then I
will dip out till after Labor Day so
I'll I'll shut down again so that I do
get the full month sort of mentally so
we will be back on September 5th that's
Monday September 5th right so because
Labor Day uh is
I'm sorry it's Tuesday September yeah
it's Tuesday September 6th
Monday Labor Day is the Monday but I
think it's the fifth that we're coming
back on Tuesday
the fifth on Tuesday thank you guys I
have a crack team here we will be back
on Tuesday the 5th because Labor Day is
Monday the fourth right so I didn't want
to come back for one day on the first
and bring all my guys back in I want
them to enjoy the summer as well so we
will be back on Tuesday the 5th after
Labor Day there you go oh but yes
Anything could happen like literally
could Biden this afternoon trip and then
it's over could they figure out a way to
install Gavin Newsom like all of the
crazy things could three of the
Republicans drop out could the aliens
are here
anything anything could happen uh
Richard says are you completely off the
grid no electronics electricity Etc or
is it that you just don't have a show
for the month so the first few years
that I did it there was no nothing I did
have electricity in my house like I'm
not shutting down I'm like going to the
to the forest although that actually
does sound kind of cool and I should
probably do something like that at some
point
um but I shut down in terms of one so
for the first few years 100 no news no
phone no iPad no computer no TV like
nothing in terms of consuming Media or
anything else yes we had lights we had a
phone
because like lights in our house and
music I do listen to music are
controlled by the phone so like we had a
phone that did not have Wi-Fi or no it
had Wi-Fi I guess but we deleted all the
apps and it did not have like an actual
it wasn't connected to a t or anything
just to open up music and that sort of
thing last year was a little bit
different because Justin was born and
obviously we had family visiting and
coming to town and calling and texting
or whatever so I had deleted a whole
bunch of apps but I did occasionally
look at this thing for the most part I
will have nothing to do with nothing I
will be all you know in terms of media
as I said it will be off all of that
stuff with kids it's a little more
complex like I need to be able to be
available at some level but yeah it's
it's the most important thing really is
is the media detox as I said that
hamster wheel thing of just slammed with
more information more craziness more
partisanship more more of the stuff
and if we can remove ourselves from that
I think it is good uh okay so that's it
for the questions for now I just want to
make a couple announcements as I leave
you guys although I said I'm really only
leaving you for an hour because we're
interviewing Rudy Giuliani at locals in
an hour from now
so a couple things this is it say
goodbye to this backdrop uh we are
building the new studio in the house uh
the contractor we started we literally
started this morning the contractor was
here this morning we've uh walls are
going up a whole bunch of stuff uh it's
gonna be awesome we're we're designing
it together we're getting new equipment
better cameras better lighting like
better audio like the whole thing we're
doing a serious investment in it and and
I'm really psyched about that uh this
background of course was my old house in
La uh and we're just using a still image
of it which looks pretty damn good and
Our intention originally when we moved
into this house a year and a half ago
was immediately to build a studio here
but then between the kids and just
everything else we were doing and
traveling it just became impossible so
this is our opportunity to do it I'm
told it'll take about three weeks and
then we have about two weeks to get the
set perfect and I can't wait to debut
that for you uh as I said we have a
bunch of off-the-grid content coming out
so stay tuned on YouTube and Rumble and
locals and all that good stuff I yes I
am many of you have asked I am still
working on that tequila the Dave Rubin
tequila it it's a it's an extremely
complex thing legally and importing
tequila
and all that we're working on that uh as
I said Rudy in an hour from locals uh
Phoenix do I have anything else I want
to tell to find people what
oh The cookbook the the man there's so
much the root the Reuben report locals
Community cookbook will officially be
posted on Monday that's recipes from me
and my team and you guys that are part
of the community and I want to thank you
guys for submitting that sorry it took
so long but we will get that up on
Monday uh and and before I go off the
grid because
um obviously I'm going to do this thing
with Rudy but that'll be mostly about
Rudy I just once again want to thank all
of you who have been any part of any of
this uh from the people that were with
me from way back when when I was on The
Young Turks to the people that started
when we first went independent or when
we were with the blaze or now that we've
done everything we're doing here when we
were in Cali in Florida when we were
broke
all of this stuff all of the stuff
um you have enabled me to do this so if
what I do here
does a little something like the tiniest
tiniest particle of something to make
the world that you live in a little bit
better then let's consider it a wash so
I do thank you and uh so there's no post
game show today because we've got to get
to locals right now because we're
interviewing Rudy in about an hour but I
do leave you with the cold clothes this
might have been I think this is probably
the funniest thing that we did all year
or just like maybe my personal did I do
drag this year was that this year yeah
that was that was the year before
Phoenix like no Dave you did drag last
year and we're never doing it again
um I I think this little thing that we
put together of Trudeau and Newsome was
like one of my favorite things and and
Connor can swear to it we did this in
one take and it was off the top of my
head one take off the top of my head and
again I thank you guys and uh we'll see
you in September
hey I'm Justin Trudeau and I'm so
excited to be here because I'm in
California with another lizard person
he's a lizard person just like me and
I'm here with him in California which
he's turned into a communist
just like I'm trying to do to Canada
we're both World economic Forum Stooges
but we have really nice
suits look at our suits and look at his
hair I just love him so much oh look at
him look at you I and I'm Gavin Newsom
look at me I smile when I'm talking so
people think I'm a nice guy but actually
I eat babies yes I do I love them
they're delicious and I'm always eating
them and then I use their blood as gel
in my hair it's very exciting for a guy
like me and I'm very happy to be here
with Justin Trudeau who is so evil that
makes me look like a good man yes isn't
it true Justin yes yes it is true yell
it you're just so cute I just love you
so much think about all of the people we
could lock in their homes and freeze
their bank accounts it's very exciting
for both of us I'm so happy about it
aren't you happy about it Kev it's just
yeah oh yeah yeah love it
good
[Music]